i'm going to read an excerpt from
chapter four
uh again the chapter called medicine and
specifically
from a section called
considering the risks of reductionism as
we choose what to put in our bodies
uh long time loyal listeners
will remember that in our very first
live stream on march something 2020
um we said that we had just that month
submitted the first draft
of of this book this book being a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
this book being a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century book we've
been talking about writing for
over a decade and it's it's it's written
now and it'll be out in september of
this year
um and uh the first draft uh
has changed the final draft has changed
a lot from the first draft but
very little in this chapter has uh and
so
um you know this was written before
kovid largely there's there's one
section not in what i'm going to read
which we actually did go back in and and
just add a paragraph
um because we were doing all the
revisions during covet but
um recognize that we wrote this based on
our lifetime of thinking evolutionarily
not within the context of a pandemic
with this with this novel virus or these
novel vaccines
so considering the risks of reductionism
as we choose what to put in our bodies
is vanillin is vanillin the same as
vanilla
is thc identical to marijuana no
in both cases a single molecule active
important in the human experience
of the larger thing vanilla or pot is
not representative of the whole
in the case of vanillin the effect
appears to have culinary ramifications
only
foods flavored with vanillin do not have
the full richness of vanilla
in the case of thc which has long been
understood to be the main psychoactive
constituent of cannabis
breeding only for that molecule made
plants that would certainly get you high
but they had insufficient anti-psychotic
tempering effects from cbd
another active molecule in pot oops
and as of this writing there is a new
marijuana molecule getting traction
about the scientific literature in the
pot breeding community
cbg it is being purported to have
benefits even greater than those of cbd
maybe but it is the human discovery of
that molecule that is elevated to the
status of being studied
it was there all along but now we've
imbued it with mystical qualities
our discovery of it changes nothing
about what it does we often mistake an
effect
for instance of an action a treatment or
a molecule for our understanding of the
effect
what a thing does and what we think or
know that it does or not the same thing
a combination of hubris and technical
capacity has humans recreating this
error over and over again
from florida drinking water to
shelf-stable foods with unintended
consequences
from the myriad issues with sun exposure
to whether gmos are safe
we are constantly seduced by
reductionist thinking led astray by the
fantasy of simplicity where the truth is
complex
reductionism particularly with respect
to our bodies and minds is harming us
sometimes it is even killing us
early in the 20th century fluoride was
discovered to be correlated with fewer
cavities
so fluoride was put into many municipal
water supplies to decrease tooth decay
the fluoride in drinking water is a
byproduct of industrial processes though
not a molecular form that appears in
nature or has ever been part of our diet
that's one point against it furthermore
we find neurotoxicity in children who
are exposed to fluoridated drinking
water
a correlation between hypothyroidism and
fluoridated water
and in salmon a loss of the ability to
navigate back to their home stream after
swimming in fluoridated water
is fluoride a magic bullet for reducing
cavities with no cost to other aspects
of health
seems not more to the point the quest
for magic bullets for simple answers
that are universally applicable to all
humans in all conditions
is misguided if it were that easy
selection would almost certainly have
found a way
think you found a solution that is too
good to be true look hard for the hidden
costs
remember chesterton's fence and i'm
going to skip over our discussion of
uh the shelf stability of processed
foods and the discussion vitamin d just
so that we have a slightly shorter
excerpt here and move into um
and also about sunscreen and move here
given this track record of reduction of
science and health advice should we
trust that gmos are safe just because
those who would profit from their
acceptance either intellectually or
financially tell us they are
we suggest not are some gmos safe
almost certainly are all gmos safe
almost certainly not
how will we know which are which and can
we rely on those who have created them
to be vigilant on our behalf
until we know the answer to those last
questions the precautionary principle
suggests
steering clear finally it is worth
noting that some of the major successes
of western medicine
surgery antibiotics and vaccines are
firmly reduced
rooted in a reductionist tradition and
have saved millions of lives
the problem we are highlighting is the
over-application of a reductionist
approach
the germ theory of disease in its
simplest formulation the recognition
that pathogens cause much disease
led to the discovery and formulation of
antibiotics a huge health boon for
humanity then we over generalized and
imagined that all microbes are bad for
us
we are now coming to realize that our
microbiome has evolved with us and is
necessary for healthy gastrointestinal
tract
antibiotics are one of relatively few
powerhouse tools of western medicine but
as they have been overprescribed we have
seen an attendant rise in people
becoming sick
often chronically so just as people are
falling ill from lacking healthy
microbiomes due to overprescription of
antibiotics
so too are our livestock furthermore
there are unintended side effects of
many antibiotics that will be shocking
to most people
my personal experience with the
unintended consequences of antibiotics
was a ruptured achilles tendon
it's now understood that tendon and
ligament injury is one side effect of
cipro and all of the antibiotics in that
class the fluoroquinolones
which um which i took in quantity in the
1990s to ward off gi bugs while
conducting research in the tropics
from fluoridated drinking water to
antifungals and shelf-stable food from
sunscreen to the overuse of antibiotics
over and over we make the same kinds of
mistakes combine reductionism with a
tendency to over-generalize
in a hyper-novel world where quick but
expensive and potentially dangerous
fixes are common
and we've explained some of the major
areas of modern health and medicine
this is exactly what we're wrestling
with here it's not going to be simple
and if someone is telling you i've got
the simple magic bullet and it's going
to allow you to get back to your life
and you're going to go out and be able
to have cocktails with your friends
without worrying ever again about covid
they probably are trying to sell you
something that isn't exactly like what
is in the package that they've got for
you
yeah um there are two things going on
one is the tendency to
over generalize from reductionism and
the other has to do
with perverse incentives and they're
both captured there i mean i remember
the world
that you and i grew up in was a world
that did regard
microbes as hostile yeah even though
microbes all everywhere well that's
exactly i mean i don't think either
actually in either of our homes but
in in many many homes lysol was probably
probably in my
my natal home i at least can tell you
what it smells like so yeah
um so it was there but yes the sense
that what one was trying to do
was to drive microbes to zero is a
preposterous
it's impossible it would be deadly
and the point is it uh misses the basic
point which is that the occasional
microbe
is dangerous and most microbes are
harmless and some microbes are essential
and
you know welcome to complex systems
[Music]
you